Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie. This will be my new Fantastic
Four Galactus video Marvel just made a casting
announcement it seems that they will be bringing
the character back for the movie they've been
trying to do Galactus in the MCU for a while
now there have been a bunch of deleted scenes
in a bunch of the writers on the upcoming Marvel
movies have talked about using him in their movies
heading into Marvel Phase 6 and Marvel phase
seven so it seems like they're finally gonna do
a legit version of Galactus which we've all been
asking for this whole time if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there'll be more casting announcements for
the new Fantastic Four movie really soon I've
already done a couple Fantastic Four videos so
I'll link those in the description below but the
first big thing supposedly they're casting Antonio
Banderas as Galactus that's a huge surprise
they highlights it probably is not actually
one movie two movies three movies it's just the
amount of one that they're actually doing Galactus
really excited about that want to see comic book
accurate Galactus in the MCU but also that they
go for Antonio Banderas now there are probably
a lot of actors that could pull off galactus's
voice because most of it would be a voice over
role but if you're gonna do a comic book accurate
Galactus he does have a humanoid looking form even
though he's highly evolved he just happens to be
a planet-sized looking person like would it be
Antonio banderas's face in galactus's helmet with
his suit the scale is again all is as it was
perfectly balanced this whole thing should be
the other obvious reason for casting a relatively
well-known very good actor would be to show him as
Galen of taa so you can learn some of galactus's
backstory a lot of people think Galactus is going
to be another Celestial in the MCU just because
he looks so similar to the celestials but he's
actually very very different he has a much
different backstory Galactus is a human from
the previous version of the universe so this is
whole cycle of Big Bangs in the Multiverse where
everything dies contracts down there's another
big bang in Another Universe another Multiverse
is born they call those the different Cosmos we're
like in the seventh or the eighth version of the
universe right now in the main MCU it's already
happened many times Galactus was named Galen of
Taw and he was one of the last survivors of the
previous version of the Multiverse he witnessed
its heat death he's sort of like a he who remains
type of character surviving to the very end of the
Multiverse and instead of being destroyed in the
process of the next big bang like every everything
else the seventh Cosmo sort of like the will the
consciousness of that entire Multiverse made a
contract with him so that they could both survive
into the next Cosmos into the next version the
Multiverse they entered the cosmic incubation
chamber and then after the big bang the next
Multiverse was born he emerges Galactus the world
eater so Galactus is kind of like a person plus
the essence of an entire Multiverse all combined
into one the funny thing about that though is that
doesn't make him more powerful than the celestials
within the comics at least he's actually fairly
afraid to go up against a Celestial host they
usually give each other pretty wide birth so
like he lets the celestials do everything that
they're supposed to be doing on a cosmic scale
like airsham the judge in the very important
Cosmic purpose that Galactus serves is kind of
like thanos's plan in Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game he gets rid of dead planets
so that new life can grow in its place sort of in
the way that farmers work with their Gardens like
they'll burn parts of their Garden to help enrich
the soil so that new life can grow so they even
though Galactus is portrayed as a world eater and
everybody hates him like oh you're gonna destroy
our world actually he serves an important Cosmic
purpose he debuted in the very early Fantastic
Four comics in a special called the coming of
Galactus and the reason why he came to consume
planet Earth is because it was so enriched with
cosmic energy within the MCU early theory is that
he's coming back to planet Earth to consume it
because of tiamit's body its Celestial body is
full of so much cosmic energy and resources that
he wants to consume that the funny thing about TMS
body is actually a big plot point during Captain
America 400 New World Order they're going to say
that adamantium and the MCU comes from his body
so it becomes this big arms race of all these
different nations including Val and Thunderbolt
Ross who's the president of the United States
to try and seize it for themselves before other
countries get it I believe it'll also play a role
in the Thunderbolts movie too so we'll see more of
what's going on with Team its body by the end of
Marvel phase 5. we talk about all the crazy cameos
are supposed to have in Deadpool 3 supposedly
because it's so tongue-in-cheek they're supposed
to have a cameo from Galactic pool in that movie
don't know how they're going to explain that hi hi
how are you you have questions yes I I had a lot
of questions I'm sure you had a lot of questions
but rest assured we're going to answer them right
now but they've been trying to get Galactus in
the MCU movies for a while now the writers of the
eternals movie were talking about doing him in
eternals 2 the sequel movie and how he sort of
figures into their Cosmic MCU plans for where
they're taking things during Marvel phase 4 in
Marvel Phase 5 on a larger Avengers level scale so
everybody's kind of been thinking about him in the
background but this is what the Marvel writers
said they said Galactus is an amazing character
and villain we are obviously setting the stage
for Intergalactic Cosmic megalith confrontations
especially when you kill a space God talking about
the plot of the eternals movie and them kind of
killing Tiamat effectively he's dead they turned
him to Stone so he's supposed to be dead and then
the space god comes and kidnaps you and plans to
judge Earth I think the door is very much open for
World eating villains technically Galactus doesn't
eat worlds he eats the cosmic energy inside worlds
but they call him the hunger so it feels kind
of like he's eating a planet then they go into
to say there's definitely conversations about
these post-credit sequences about what they're
introducing where we're going Galactus is one of
those iconic figures of the Marvel universe that
we're excited to see but sometimes I think you
leave yourself open you leave the doors open and
who knows what's happening in number two maybe
you're too busy saving a Celestial from Galactus
that you end up incurring his wrath anything is
possible that should answer all your questions
about why Galactus didn't show up in a post-credit
scene it sounds like they thought about it but
it was just a little too soon to actually bring
him into the MCU because we haven't seen Silver
Surfer yet and they haven't done the new
Fantastic Four movie yet but clearly the
eternal's writers have had a lot of conversations
with Marvel behind the scenes about how they use
Galactus in the next movie The Plot that he
explains there might change a little but he's
suggesting the Galactus would actually be fighting
the celestials just because of this big megalith
Cosmic confrontations they're talking about there
aren't that many characters that are physically as
large as Galactus in the celestials but they're
about the same size like Galactus about the same
size as airshin the judge sort of like God's
Zilla vs Kong but make it Marvel and make it
outer space nature he's in our control I'm not the
other way around Let them fight that would be a
little bit different from his relationship to the
celestials in the comics in the comics Galactus
actually views them as being the bigger fish if
you're talking about apex predators in fact the
Eternal story that they adapted for the movie Neil
gaiman's eternals run with Tiamat the dreaming
Celestial waking up and the Eternal is trying
to stop that from happening on Earth Galactus
was actually featured in that story and starts to
get afraid when it senses that a new Celestial is
being born but based on what the eternal's writers
said it sounds like in the MCU they're going to be
using Galactus in a slightly different way making
him more powerful than the celestials or at least
as powerful the plot that the eternals writers
teased here the eternals themselves saving a
Celestial from Galactus they didn't say if it's a
fully grown Celestial or if it's saving Celestial
seeds in planets from Galactus but his whole
thing is consuming planets rich in cosmic energy
he doesn't actually eat the plants themselves like
I said he just sucks the cosmic energy out of them
in planets with Celestial seeds in the MCU would
be super rich in that that kind of energy like
a tasty Galactus snack the other real big deleted
scene with Galactus relatively recently was during
Thor love and thunder and because this is a huge
deal literally and metaphorically like you have a
lot of huge monsters Galactus literally huge what
was originally going to happen is that we were
going to see Jane Foster's Mighty Thor Adventures
on Earth while Thor was busy with the Guardians of
the Galaxy before he'd come back to earth so like
Jane Foster's Thor vs Galactus would have happened
during a completely different part of the movie
and I think it's easy to understand why they got
rid of this part of the movie because there are
so many big characters that they're just burning
through super quickly is a sort of jokey kind of
way and since the eternals movie Just sets up so
much Cosmic history of the MCU it makes sense
that they'd also use Galactus in some way or
incorporate him into the celestial's overarching
story going forward and bringing this back around
to the new Fantastic Four movies that Marvel is
setting up right now Galactus sort of goes hand
in hand with the Silver Surfer character usually
you see him first and he is the herald of Galactus
so then you know the Galactus is coming when he
shows up I haven't heard any casting announcements
about Silver Surfer yet I've only heard talk about
Galactus being in the movie so let me know who you
want to play Silver Surfer also because of where
they're taking that character in future movies
he's just a really huge deal in the MCU you
may remember Lawrence Fishburne's performance
as Silver Surfer in the original Fantastic Four
movies he was just the voice of the character Doug
Jones did the physical camera performance it is
known by many names why people called it Galactus
the Devourer of worlds my early Theory right now
for the first time we actually see Galactus for
real in the MCU the first time they actually
tease him would be one of the new Fantastic
Four movies post-credit scenes like the new
Fantastic Four movie introduces the new team
what their big mission is going to be they use one
of the post-credits scenes as a sort of Avengers
5 Avengers 6 lead-in for larger Cosmic Avengers
Level Threats like Galactus but everyone let me
know in the comments if the eternals writers are
talking about using Galactus in the sequel movies
what do you actually want them to do with the
character we'll get more casting announcements
really soon but Marvel's next big series is the
secret Invasion episodes I will do episode videos
for that like all the other Marvel series and
we do have a new Loki season 2 trailer coming
pretty soon too I just did a big video for the
last Loki season 2 trailer you can click here
to watch that and click here for that brand
new Adam Driver Fantastic Four announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!